[Music]
recently serena williams retired from
tennis and for most athletes you know
after a long and
successful career
retirement is a time for bittersweet
reflection it's a time for uh gratitude
but gratitude has never quite been the
serena williams way i suppose neither
has maturity nor dignity nor likability
and so serena staying true to form
is riding into the sunset with her 260
million net worth and whining the whole
way out in fact she says that her
retirement is not prompted by her age
but by sexism
cnbc reports tennis legend serena
williams has been a fierce advocate for
gender equality both on and off the
court and when she announced her
retirement from the sport tuesday
morning she made an important point
about the unique sacrifices women must
make in their careers in a vogue article
williams who turns 41 next month said
that she will retire after the us open
which begins in late august
the winning tournament would tie her
with margaret court's record of 24 grand
slam titles
quote i have never liked the word
retirement williams wrote in the article
which was transcribed from her
conversation with vogue contributor rob
haskell maybe the best word to describe
what i'm up to is evolution i'm here to
tell you that i'm evolving away from
tennis toward other things that are
important to me
okay well so far so good right that's
that's all that's all fine i guess
almost i mean the whole uh
i'm not retiring on evolving bit it's
pretty annoying and pretentious but i'm
willing to overlook it and actually i
looked up the full quote serena williams
actually said that um
she would describe herself as in the
middle of a transition but she doesn't
want to use that word because she
doesn't want to appropriate it from
trans people
that's what she said but we're going to
let that go because we have other
problems to deal with the article
continues
williams cited her family as the main
reason why she'll step away from the
sport writing that her four-year-old
daughter olympia wants to be a big
sister williams has been married to
reddit founder alexis ohanian since
2017 the desire to expand her family
however wouldn't be a career-ending move
if she were a man williams points out
believe me i never wanted to have to
choose between tennis and a family she
wrote i don't think it's fair if i were
a guy i wouldn't be writing this because
i'd be out there playing and winning
while my wife was doing the physical
labor of expanding our family maybe i'd
be more of a tom brady if i had that
opportunity
okay
so there's the problem
and
it's difficult to know
exactly how to respond to that because
it's so crushingly stupid and incoherent
it's it's also self-contradictory as she
was just worried about being sensitive
to trans people and now here she is
making the transform transphobic claim
that men don't have babies and that's
very problematic
but that aside it's not clear
what her complaint is exactly
like she whines that men don't have to
do the physical labor of expanding the
family but what does that mean
is is she referring to the fact
that women are more likely to be the
primary caretakers of children
well that can't be it because she has
hundreds of millions of dollars and
certainly already has an army of nannies
and various other servants on standby
she's not home every day raising her
current four-year-old daughter she's
obviously made arrangements there so why
couldn't she do the same thing for the
next child
when you've got 200 million dollars in
the bank uh there's there's no reason
why if you don't want it to the reason
why having a kid would stop you from
doing anything you want to do
if you have no problem with having a
nanny raise them
or is she
when she says physical labor is she
actually referring to the labor of labor
is she talking about the fact that women
are the ones who physically bear and
deliver children well we could only
assume that that's what she meant and if
so her complaint is less petty and
selfish than it is just insane
i mean it's not fair that women are the
ones who give birth what
who what do you mean not fair who are
you registering this complaint with
exactly
nature god
or do you imagine that human
reproduction is a patriarchal conspiracy
as if sinister white men in smoky rooms
conspired to set things up this way
calling a woman's role in human
reproduction unfair
is like saying it's unfair
that birds can fly and we can't or it's
unfair that gumdrops don't fall from the
sky when it rains
it's unfair that there isn't actually uh
a pot of gold at the end of a rainbow
an unfair thing is a thing that happens
outside
of the rules or not in accordance with
the principles of justice that's what's
unfair so what rule
what principle of justice is violated by
the nature of human reproduction
any claim of unfairness is an appeal to
some higher authority or principle so
again who or what is being appealed to
here
to top it all off serena is bitterly
complaining about a pregnancy that
hasn't happened yet she's going to try
to get pregnant potentially having to
use medical assistance given her age and
and yet she's complaining the whole way
as if the thing she's planning to do in
the future and says she wants to do is
nonetheless gonna happen against her
will it makes no sense
well that's not exactly true
i can make some sense of this
serena williams
like any sufficiently modern and
progressive western person
um hates herself
and she rejects herself
see
the way she sees it is that
her femaleness
is somehow apart from her true self
right like there's there's her herself
there's her and then there's there's her
femaleness and her femaleness intrudes
on her true self
causing inconveniences and interfering
with her tennis career
she does not see herself as a completely
integrated whole
and that's because nobody on the left
does
they divide themselves into pieces and
put aspects of themselves at war with
other aspects of themselves
they become bitter and sullen feeling
somehow persecuted by nature itself
though they can't explain how and they
don't know who to complain to about it
and the great shame in serena's case and
in the case of so many leftist women
is that is that
while she's doing all this complaining
you know she's failing to see the
blessing
she sees as a curse what is really a
blessing
a woman's ability to conceive to harbor
and bring forth new life onto the earth
is a beautiful
miraculous gift
and you know what it's something far
more significant and important
than swinging a tennis racket around
so it's not just that she's complaining
and whining about it
oh why do i have to be the one to give
birth
well that's one way of looking at it i
guess
but the healthier way of looking at it
the way that has more gratitude and will
make you a happier person that also
makes a lot more sense
is to say i get to be the one
you know i have been blessed with this
enormous gift and also power
that men don't have
but as we already discussed gratitude
is unfortunately far outside the reach
of
people like serena williams and that is
why she is today
on the cusp of her retirement
cancelled
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really as that's what
it is we're joy we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
uh this video to stay up to date with
all my content and if you want even more
you can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang